they say there's an eclipse there's a
black hole is whatever we need what's
this one
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by your personal
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson he's
the director of the Hayden Planetarium
you know him from his work on cosmos
Startalk and as many books and speaking
of you can pick up his latest
astrophysics for people in a hurry
available in May
Neil welcome to the show thanks and
thank for the plug I thought you know I
had to earn it and then you plug the
book but now if you plug in a verse I
could like leave now that's true that's
true
nobody's never hacked our show we're
gonna loophole whoa how are you without
food I could hang we'll see if you can
hang I can hang maybe maybe not with you
but I can hang we'll work our way up to
Megadeth's are you ready to get it going
Megadeth Megadeth that means millions of
deaths
[Music]
if these get hotter hotter and hotter I
will probably not be eating all of
what's hotter and hotter how so I'm
gonna eat the whole first one how about
that that's a great idea that's a great
strategy Neal so in your book
astrophysics for people in a hurry you
talked about how the shipping industry
could save billions of dollars if they
shipped in spheres rather than boxes
because I read the book on Saturday so
it's still fresh in my mind and it has
me thinking about all the other ways
that we leave time and money and energy
on the table by being locked in these
conventions are there some other things
that drive you nuts in everyday life
because you know as a society we can
just do them easier better smarter yeah
I mean there's a lot of scientific
engineering solutions to problems we're
if you're not scientifically we're
engineering ly literate you don't even
know that that would simplify it can you
give me an example well okay let's be
blunt okay if you say why would spending
money up there and not down here where
we have the problems when the asteroid
comes you're gonna wish we had spent
money up there you didn't know how to
deflect the asteroid and so we see this
I know the asteroids I see where they
are I know how many they are no we gotta
solve these problems here on earth now
some of these problems will protect a
generation not yet born are you only
thinking about yourself or the future of
Earth as well
in terms of scientific accuracy what's
the best science fiction movie of all
time I have to say the Martian of all
time even though that just came out you
know a year ago two years ago the
Martian I think before the Martian no
one imagined you can invest that much
science in storytelling and have it be a
first-run movie I think so Laura cop
drama they're so comfortable reaching
for tropes that they know have worked
before and they were certain reaching
for science would not do that for them
so somebody had to break the mold the
ball has been busted open from the
botany to the chemistry to the
engineering to the physics to the
astrophysics it's all there is there an
animated series or a cartoon that kind
of impress is you is there's something
out there they get it right more often
than not Oh animated there's a lot of
math in the Simpsons I think it's not so
much that you'd want a cartoon that's
always reaching for science because it's
not necessary but what you would want is
when they do go to science they get it
right they get it right and for having
gotten it right they get to tell a
richer story so I'm a fan of what Mark
Twain says first get your facts straight
then distort them at your leisure so in
addition to being a connoisseur of the
cosmos I know that you're also an
aficionado of fine wines is that because
you were obsessed with the science of
fermentation or you just wanted to drink
I mean I think if you'd like fine food
you also will discover that you'll like
wine that goes with it think about we
have five traditional senses and sight
and hearing taste touch and smell each
one of these senses Garner's an entire
fraction of society's investment in
bringing pleasure to those senses think
about it so your sense of hearing I want
music and you'll invest money in this
you'll go to concerts there's great
works of art there's beautiful
architecture look at how much we invest
and things that look beautiful and as
odd when you think about it that you can
go home and eat a bowl of rice some
beans with it and get most of you in
maybe a salad and that's your nutrition
and that would cost you
a dollar in raw ingredients or you can
go to a restaurant and spend hundreds of
dollars on food and wine the fact that
people do that at all means you can
raise the sense of human Airy
satisfaction to extremely high levels
and people do so I like a good bottle of
wine where I'm distracted by how good it
is so that I do sleep at night wondering
how the winemaker accomplished that feat
can't wait til Megadeth you can wait so
these days I'm sure you spend more time
than you'd like to bunking conspiracy
theories so what I'm hoping I can do is
that you can give me kind of an idiot's
guide for how to deal with these various
issues so that if I'm ever at a bar and
some flat earth or comes up to me I can
quickly expose them and get back to my
drink does that sound okay so what I
don't do what do you know they feel this
way mm-hmm and I've done it once maybe
twice but what I don't do is debunk
crazy ideas I spend my whole life doing
that I'm an educator my task is not to
debunk the crazy ideas of adults but
establish an educational system that is
incapable of producing an adult that
thinks that way in the first place well
let me ask you this you know you've been
at it for a long time over the last 10
years or so have you seen an increase in
the number of people who maybe think
these things I think that number of
people may be the same over time they
just now can write a blog the whole
world has access to via a search engine
right you'd be alone with your own view
that has no correspondence to objective
reality and you type it into a Google
search and it'll find every other person
like you who thinks the same way giving
you the false sense that you're actually
autism that you have some deep insight
into the world that no
as this is delusional the internet
landed in our laps without creating a
curriculum that empowers you to know
when someone online is full of [ __ ]
there's a little bit it's like a
pineapple
kind of sweetness in it what does the
pineapple blend in there Neal really
some people don't pick that up yeah I
said I eat my food I love this all right
so the next part of the show is a
recurring segment called explain that
grandma what we do is we do a deep dive
on our guests Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context you're a
little inactive so for you we pulled up
some oldies all the goodies
what would actually yeah so so I'm
totally with you on Twitter I'm gonna
try to bust into the Instagram world
this is exciting
I'm a little slow but let your audience
will be the first to know that I plan to
be there but it's not gonna be like
anything else I care a lot about art and
and so I have a set of I'm just gonna
put pretty photos on my Instagram I
think that sounds nice Neal but I also
would say don't paint yourself into a
corner already Neal you haven't even
gotten your Instagram account off the
first one oh hey you and Buzz all the
man buzz me and Buzz were chillin people
say oh he wasn't the first to walk on
the moon they landed on the moon in the
same vessel at the same moment yes so
I'm not who's first to second ID and it
was 10,000 scientists and engineers that
got him there right at a hundred billion
dollars in taxpayer money we all landed
on the moon together that is our boot
print okay that's how I look at it but
Buzz he's been added ever since Neil
Armstrong went and became professor of
aerospace engineering it buzz kept
trying to get us back into space
we're boldly going where hundreds of
gone before it so it's time to go
someplace new so he's wearing a shirt
that just says get your ass to Mars and
I couldn't help but not take a picture
pointing to the word ass I got two more
for yell I mean you did some homework
back here next we have oh okay so this
photo is my very first in-and-out burger
did it live up to the hype nothing wrong
with it but I was I wanted to be at your
bar I wanted to be transported and I was
not transported here's the difference I
think
okay in-and-out is a fast-food joint
that makes a really good burger mm-hmm
whereas Shake Shack is a gourmet chef
making a fast-food burger okay that's
where that's this is for me what that
difference is
Oh classic selfie oh oh okay iconic so
here's the back story behind that we
weren't a receiving line for the
president we made sure we were at the
end of the line we navigated this
because we know who didn't want to take
a selfie you don't do that with the
president anybody say come over here let
me grab you and like give him a new key
on the free you know that's not how he's
supposed to treat the president right so
I was the last in line and I say mr.
president you know we'd like to just
take a selfie with me and Bill there
maybe it'll break the internet why not
and then he teeth he was a good trooper
I was fully planning to take the selfie
myself and then I did it no space left
No in that moment oh oh and then Bill
Nye whipped it out and he saved the day
even though we're both positioned like
it could have been either of our selfies
it was Bill Nyes camera taking that
selfie this I'm saving after we get to
10 mm maybe I'll say why wasn't there an
11 did I go there did I just say that
whoa
let me see if I can hit you with this
one because it's an endless topic of
fascination for our viewers and our
commenters is how you stop the pain of
spicy wings you know there are people
like why do you have water out on the
table like Oh blah blah blah you need
this you need that did anything go
through your head before you came here
to like prepare for it it's not about it
but not not because I had done
experiments but just I was trying to
wonder what would happen if I had a RICO
law before I came in
that's what a coach your throat if you
have a sensitive throat I'm a fan of if
you're an Indian restaurant having a
good lawsuit mango lasse that works
every time plus I love mango
[Music]
hell of zombies zombies a good but some
bees prefer your brains you ran ahead
and think about hops off Joe say that
went up quite a few notches from these
six yeah so when we have artists in here
usually we like to have them decode some
of their lyrics but now that you're here
I think it would be great if I could
give you some of the most infamous
science inspired rap lyrics of all time
and I just wonder how they'll hit your
ear as an astrophysicist you know maybe
you look very impressed by him you
actually the crack team of researchers
who dug up these lines yeah Chris I mean
Chris this morning really uh getting
dirty all right this first one is from
Kanye West it's off getting it in by
Jadakiss make it to your anus okay
Uranus is Uranus until you're like eight
years old then they're on it's Uranus so
that's an abomination but you give it to
until you're like graduate third grade
and you know and you get out of your
your anal success fixations your
scatological referencing um so I I would
say that was not an example of an artist
who is first getting their facts
straight and then distorting them at
their leisure all right this one's from
OJ the juice man that's awful
I'm getting money
[Music]
I like that I like that cuz of course
thunderous sound it's not light but
thunder is so striking that you not only
hear it you feel it if you're close
enough to it it rumbles your chest so I
have no problems with anybody saying
that the thunder was experienced through
more than one of their senses this is
from immortal technique the song is
called dominant species on the technique
and you're nobody so what you try to say
Stella density becomes your physical
alignment 1.8 billion tons per square
inch can find me hmm whoa let me think
1.8 billion tons that is the density of
a white dwarf star approximately the
density of what the Sun will be on death
and I think he's reaching in pulling out
he's reaching in in the Canon of
astrophysics pulling out some words and
some numbers and he's just throwing him
down on his on his rhyme sheet and I
give him credit for reaching in and
pulling out some references but I don't
think he understands the full context
for them which then subtracts from how
deep his song actually is versus how
deep he thinks it is so this next one is
from GZA it's off Big Bang I'm just
gonna be that's it I've had him on my
radio show star talk I'm betting I will
have very little say about it I other
than compliments but go on
the small atom we good can I do how can
you be hotter than zombie apocalypse the
bomb is hotter the bomb is hotter dub
bomb oh this is fat boy oh my gosh okay
so that is the proportions of one of the
two bombs dropped in the Second World
War and it says radioactive that's
correct except that's not the scariest
part of the bomb is that it will blow
you to smithereens vaporize you so it
should be caution will vaporize you
not just then it's radioactive who to
miss the old radioactive side really
makes you want to eat it you know huh
all right let's do this
[Music]
I took two bites [ __ ] did I just say
that please make him eat you
he's making me do this that's pretty hot
that's hot
so you're named the sexiest
astrophysicist by People magazine but
people might not know women that was 40
pounds ago first of all I think it still
holds up God still holds ons ago 17
years ago I'm just saying but people
might not know that your roots as this
scientific sex symbol are actually even
a little bit deeper than that is it true
that you are tempted to moonlight as a
male exotic dancer when you're a
graduate student at the University of
Texas yeah yeah briefly I wasn't a
performing member of a dance company and
so one of my fellow dancers male dancers
said why don't you come down to the club
and I said why but while we dance there
and you get tips and things I said all
right I'll observe it so I go there the
guys came out in jockstraps only but
they were asbestos lined and lighter
fluid had been poured onto them and they
were ignited and they came out dancing
to Jerry Lee Lewis his great balls of
fire and in that moment I'm disappointed
that not until that moment did it occur
to me maybe I should tutor math instead
am i this ice used to come up to here I
don't breathe in on the ice that is melt
and ice down I got this okay so what's
next Mad Dog 357
oh so 3 600 M I guess so you have such
an influential bull I like this one
you like Mad Dog 357 I like it I think
because yeah it's heat its be content
mm-hmm is very uniformly spread in all
sensory points in my mouth so my entire
mouth is participating in this and I
respect it for that this one is creating
a loom a full bouquet a full bouquet of
hotness so you have such an influential
bullhorn and as one of the most famous
public intellectuals I'm sure that you
figure out the hard way that sometimes
facts can be kind of a PR nightmare and
sometimes you can cause a little bit of
a kerfuffle with some of your comments
how about when you downgraded Pluto down
Greenville had it coming just don't get
me started then did the fallout surprise
you yes it's a big fall it did because
we didn't in fact downgrade Pluto all we
did was say Pluto looks more like these
objects than those objects so in our
exhibit tree and we were the first
out-of-the-box to do this 17 years ago
and when we opened the new Rose Center
for Earth and space here in New York the
that we took Pluto a grouped it with
other icy bodies that have been
discovered in the outer solar system
Pluto and they look more alike than
either one of them looks like any of the
other planets
the New York Times caught wind of this
page once below the fold the page one
story
Pluto not a planet only in New York
that's when the hate mail started coming
from third graders your doctor said why
you take away my favorite my favorite
planet that's where it started and they
who were in third grade in the year 2000
have now graduated college I think that
I do the math right yeah third grade
hate there you're adults now and it's
still pissed off well have one bone to
pick with you
it's the Manhattanhenge because you
popularize the Manhattanhenge yeah and
now every time the Manhattanhenge is a
thing there's a bunch of amateur
photographers on 34th Street just out
there with their phony blocking traffic
completely blocking traffic I as a kid
when I was fifteen I did research at
Stonehenge in England with the guy who
decoded it and discovered that it was an
astronomical observatory but some temple
where the Druids sacrificed virgins
whatever so I said well the least I
could do for the city is just find the
day of the year where it lines up with
the street grid because as we know all
of Manhattan is an rectilinear grid but
rotated from true north about 30 degrees
so I rotated that's right about from
true north so let me just calculate that
take a picture of it and publish it and
that's what I did so that so my first
picture of this was published in January
2002 a special issue of Natural History
Magazine and there it is rising exactly
on the Manhattan grid and it's
Manhattanhenge the buildings are the
hinges and there's the Sun lined with it
and I and and it started out real slow
and now there are thousands of people
blocking traffic and I asked you if you
had to have traffic blocked isn't it
best to be blocked by the cosmos itself
rather than by coned digging a hole
that's my question to you where you get
your traffic blocked uncountable numbers
of times by uncountable numbers of other
causes and effects let the universe has
its own two damn days in the Sun
I'm shaking it up you're probably
wondering why I'm wondering why all
right well it's tradition around here to
dab the last wing with a little extra
you don't have to if you don't want to
Neil deGrasse Tyson but I would say this
you're holding up pretty well just a
little just a little something for the
people you don't have to feel with
Blair's mega like I said they need to
update to Giga and tera lots more that's
it there's beaches a factor of a
thousand greater Megadeth softs with I
can't pronounce this
oh oh sorry liquid rage I was like I got
that one for you liquid rage so here we
are mm-hmm careful me a little haha this
is some slow moving sauce yeah but once
sometimes it kind of title me I gotcha
are you ready let's twos together ready
ready cheers Cheers near wing bum wing
bomb
[Music]
the liquid now has ax cuz liquid the
liquid Rach the liquid the liquid so now
I have the liquid is going up into my
olfactory cavity and now I don't have
the sniffles at all
so now that you've eaten ten scorching
hot chicken wings on YouTube with a bald
guy I think this is now as good a time
as any
talk about how insignificant we all are
on this scheme of things with the liquid
rage digging into your soul right now I
do wonder can you explain what our
current suffering means in the context
of a potentially infinite galaxy no no
but here's my thing
yeah we have come to define significance
as I'm special everything else isn't
religions thinking they're special
cultures thinking they're special
individuals thinking they're special the
top four ingredients in life in your
body top 4 atoms in order hydrogen
oxygen carbon nitrogen those four atoms
do you don't the top ingredients are in
the universe the top four chemically
active atoms in the universe hydrogen
oxygen carbon nitrogen
I am the universe yes so upon learning
that you're not special because you do
not contain special ingredients is the
same fact that includes that the idea
[Music]
that while we live in this universe the
universe lives within us we are special
because we're the same there it is there
it is Neil deGrasse Tyson and you
cleared the board you made it through
the hot sauces you did it with look at
all I'm still he's going he's going for
another fight he's going from this
direction what a legend this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
so not entirely what I seem I'd rather
just stay home but you know what happens
the universe gets under people's skin
and they want to know more about it and
then I get the phone call we need we
need a comment
will you come give a comment well this
is like the bat-signal
this was like the cosmic seeking and I'm
a servant of your cosmic curiosity
that's what I am I'm not a enough force
I don't want to force it on anyone I
respect that and that's you have to be
sure that's what you have to do to look
in the mirror but as a talk-show host
but I have to do to look myself in the
mirror as I have to make sure that I
come through for the guests so I'll do
it I'm gonna do it the book is called
astrophysics for people in a hurry and
it really does work for people in a
hurry because I slammed right through
this thing in a weekend there you go
[Applause]
so you're eating them along with me
right along with you we're gonna be
recorded again now no you're not rolling
so what is your evidence for me that you
were tasting the same sauces on your
wings I'm open to whatever you want to
do if you wanted to switch boards I love
this already already hey what's going on
hot ones fans if you like the video
maybe meet us halfway throw us a
subscribe if you didn't like the video
don't subscribe I don't want you I don't
want you in the tent but if you liked
the video subscribe thank you very much
I appreciate you I love you more than a
friend